so who are the top contenders who is on
the list that Senator Schumer referred
to Kerry Severino is chief counsel and
policy director at judicial crisis
network and she joins us now and Kerry
thanks for coming on so before we get to
the list let me ask you just as it as a
factual matter is it possible for
Democrats to prevent the president from
installing a new Supreme Court justice
look right now the Republicans control
the Senate they have 51 votes that's all
they need to confirm a Supreme Court
nominee and what I predict is we get a
nominee who is basically Gorsuch 2.0
same same playbook find someone who has
got great judicial experience is fair is
balanced has bipartisan and broad public
support I don't see how they could
possibly get the votes to stop anomaly
like that and I think that's that's
excellent because that's exactly why the
American people put President Trump in
this position tonight they wanted
someone who would be honoring the
Constitution in the laws that way so
you're confident that was Senator McCain
out dealing with his illness and that
the president would get the full support
of every Republican in the Senate and
that there would be enough Republicans
president present for a quorum to get
this through obviously you know with
with such a narrow margin you do have to
make sure everyone is there you can't
have anyone out on a trip or out sick
however you know again these these are
the best of the best if you look at this
list of nominees and I know we're going
to it is some of the brightest legal
minds in the country so I just think it
was a shoo-in who's on it well there's
people who are obviously aside from Mike
Lee everyone else has records on the
judiciary you have people who have
served on their state supreme courts
people like Joan Larson and David
Strasse who both of them were on state
Supreme Court's now on federal courts
Don will it same thing in the Texas
Supreme Court you have people who had
experience of district courts as well
like a multiple and then you have you
have people who spent years for example
a brick cavern on the DC Circuit lots of
experience and administrative law and
one of the longer records of the judges
so these are really some of the stars of
the leaks of federal and state
judiciary's and I think any one of them
would be a
using replacement for Justice Kennedy
red Cavanaugh is impressive guy for sure
Cary thank you for that overview
appreciate it Thanks